- I mean, how is dating
just horrendous now?
- Well I did meet my
boyfriend and he's wonderful,
but--
- How many, wait,
how, what were these people?
You find, how are, of course, adorable,
okay, here's my thing.
- I know, he's so cute.
- How did it, it's always, how
do you find so many people?
Like, how do you do that?
Like you know what I'm saying?
Like, no, I have these girlfriends
and I'm like, how do you,
how do you just meet
someone out of nowhere?
Like, how do you,
I went on a date--
- I went on a dating app.
- You did?
- I did it.
- Oh.
- I--
- I'm too shy for that.
I think bone collector or something.
(laughing)
like I just think,
I think Dateline special,
I'm afraid of it.
- My mom
was so mad at me when I told her I did it,
she was like, I cannot
believe you did that.
And now--
- Well, look what you found,
he's adorable.
- I know.
And it's like, I always
say to her, I'm like,
you're obsessed with him
- Yeah,
- and you wouldn't
talk to me because I joined a dating app
and yeah, I just went on a few dates.
- So wait, on the dating app
do you disclose like right
off the bat who you are
or do you kind of?
- No, I just was very vague about it.
- I love that.
- Yeah.
- That's kind of cool.
- He had no idea
anything about about me.
- Oh, that's kind of rad then.
- Yeah, but he did, he was like
right before I got, we went,
okay, our first day is kind of funny like
I had been doing,
I had, had like four other dates before
and none of them were that good,
but I started documenting 'em
like for my own personal like self,
I was like-
- About how bad they were
and funny.
- I would like go to the bathroom
and then I would document like,
okay, this is just not going well,
like, I don't know what to do,
I'm gonna call my friend,
I'm gonna send her the text
where she has to call me
and like do the whole thing.
- Yeah.
- So did this whole
documentation of that, put
it on YouTube, oops and.
(laughing)
- Wait, were these people on there
or did you not say who it was?
- No.
I would go to the bathroom.
- I was like damn,
- No.
- that's like worse than
a Taylor Swift song,
I was like damn.